Jennifer Aniston spotted without her  wedding ring the 49 year old actress was  all smiles as she left bestie Courtney  Cox's Beverly Hills home on Tuesday  night rocking a long black coat white  tee and chic ripped jeans her ring from  Justin Theroux nowhere in sight my life  seems so much more dramatic and  interesting than it is the girls night  in comes just two weeks after Jen and  Justin announced they called it quits in  late 2017 after two and a half years of  marriage the former pair have been  staying under the radar since they  revealed their separation and a source  told et the row will be staying out of  the limelight for a while to adjust to  his split from Aniston what do you do to  blend into the public to blend into the  public you're not seeing a baseball  there's a trick which is baseball has to  go like this  [Music]